en 1975 le maréchal de bouvent
inspectent la frontière de l'est
réalisant l'importance militaire de
belfort et de son château
il décide de rendre imprenable cette
place forte
par ap fortifications et chaud gars ont
alors érigé et le château de belfort
renaît de ses cendres
en effet au xiiie siècle il existait
déjà une maquette réalisée d'ailleurs
par le colonel bretonnier des écoutes
montrent que le château féodal était
plus un village fortifié qu'un bâtiment
militaire vauban lui donnait à caractère
moderne et c'est surtout le général haxo
en 1817 qui le transforme et lui donnent
son cachet actuel fait rempart édifiées
par vauban qui entouraient la ville
souvent c'est à dire ici à vos pieds la
via ferrata recommencer si juste en
dessous de vous sur votre gauche pour
rejoindre la première tour bastionnée 7
thourottois pentagonale ou toit pointu
que vous avez juste au bout de ce pâté
de maisons rectif vous allez à droite
vous apercevez la seconde tout nous
voyons juste son toit si vous ne voyez
pas vous prenez la basilique saint
christophe l'église au milieu de la cité
la tour de gauche et dans la diagonale
vous apercevez ce toit pointu toujours
un droit fils est en partie gâché par le
feuillage la troisième tour nous voyons
toujours juste son toit et donc ensuite
les remparts qui se terminait l'entier
de sa chatte neufchâteau et surtout
devenu célèbre en 1877 d'infos chou et
sa fameuse résistance contre les
prussiens
le jour de sa nomination d' enfer avait
annoncé de la situation nous sommes
citoyens soldats
nous n'avons qu'un devoir vaincre ou
mourir il va avoir bientôt l'occasion de
donner un sens à cette phrase ses seize
mille hommes mal vécu peu armés ont
résisté durant cent trois jours à une
armée prussienne doter d'un armement
moderne pourtant le château de belfort
grâce au dispositif dax au s'avèra
prenable et quand le gouvernement
français donne l'ordre d'évacuation le
18 février 1871
l'époux siens qui ont bombardé 73 fois
la place s'attendent à trouver des
ruines
en fait le château a résisté il est
sérieusement écorchée mais nullement
entamée vous avez ici un plan du château
de belfort tels qu'ils étaient 170 s'est
elle se présente encore à peu près à
l'heure actuelle sur cette maquette et
sur le plan fisac te ment vous pouvez
suivre l'évolution du château depuis le
moyen-âge sq en effet au moyen-âge le
château était limitée de la manière
suivante limitée seulement évidemment
ces constructions n'existait pas cette
dette est limité à l'est par un peu
c'est est actuellement recouvert et qui
forme un grand souterrain
puis une muraille seront des quelques
petits tours que vous avez là et qu'elle
ait tous les pouvoirs d'un mur iron est
ensuite en suivant la ligne de l'aveu au
xviie siècle tout d'abord le pont de la
suze puis vous ment elle est installée
le fossé que vous avez la vue du grand
couronnées et le reste des défenses a
été construit par le général haxo ses
fortifications donc été assez important
puisqu'elles ont consisté dans
l'installation et de fossés défensif
aussi sec
bien entendu qui se trouve là et
également du rempart que nous à maurice
lors de signal caverton n'ai jamais eu
de fossé rempli d'eau pour les possédés
vela sont défaussés sec défendue par m
ce château au cours de la visite laisse
entrevoir une foule de curieux à 100
puis millénaire fort et peut-être par
les romains dont on a réparé la margelle
et qui a fourni jusqu'en 1944 vols
nécessaires la garnison du château
c'est pierre signé sûrement par des
compagnons bâtisseurs tailleur de pierre
qui ainsi avait la possibilité non
seulement de travée à jamais leur nom
sur la façade du château mais aussi
qu'ils pouvaient de cette façon
alice se faire payer exactement le prix
de leur travail
n'oublions pas non plus les célèbres
canon le filon et le mandarin qui
montent la garde pointé sur l'effort des
hautes et basses sèche enfin le
processeur intel il accepte un escalier
de 72 mhz à ce que croient comme le
château nommé fort et surtout
remarquable par ses dimensions et parce
qu'il est resté à peu près complet c'est
à dire que depuis une centaine d'années
il est resté comme on l'avait bâti comme
on l'avait prévu
le sport et c'est le seul endroit
historique le seul bâtiment historique
en somme qui existent dans toute la
région
parce que toute la région a été une ou
deux fois par siècle ravagé par les
invasions si bien que nous n'avons pas
de belles maisons comme par exemple à
cou noir ou dans la paix ne lasse pas il
n'ya que ici où les gens se sont
toujours réfugiées sur ce rocher une
sports c'est pour ça que les habitants
des forêts de la région
ils sont très attachés liste de la
caserne de crozon été transformée en
musée
elle a pris deux magnifiques collections
d'armes tout provenant de la région d'el
fourtet de l'été ou arbalète du
moyen-âge au document de la guerre de 14
en passant par les tapis des soldats de
denfert rochereau
les amateurs de vielles larmes de
souvenirs enfouis si des fois satisfaire
leur curiosité
chaque année des milliers de visiteurs
étrangers au français 18 ce château
vivante leçon d'histoire une magnifique
piste d'élan pour les rêves les plus
fous